Another method that we could use to impute missing
values in a data set is to perform linear regression
to estimate the missing values. We'll cover linear regression
in more depth in the next lesson. But the general
idea is that we would create an equation that
predicts missing values in the data using information we do
have, and then use that equation to fill in our
missing values. Okay so, what are the drawbacks of using
this linear regression type technique? Well, one negative
side effect of imputing missing values in this
way is that we would over emphasize existing
trends in the data. For example, if, if
there is a relationship between date of birth
and height in MLB players, all of our
imputed values will amplify this trend. Additionally, this
model will produce exact values for the missing entries,
which would suggest a greater certainty in the missing values than
we actually have. In any case, let's say we did want
to fill in the missing values for weight in our baseball
player data. We could train a linear model using the existing
data that we have, and then use that model to fill
in these missing values. Let's say we did want to fill
in the missing values for weight in our baseball data. We
could train a linear model using our existing data. That is,
entries that have position, left or right
handed batter, average, birthdate, deathdate, height and
weight. And then use that model that
we've created to fill in these missing values.